- À l'arrivée des négociateurs
russes et ukrainiens en Turquie,
les attentes n'étaient pourtantt
pas très élevées.
"Le monde entier attend
de bonnes nouvelles de votre
part", a déclaré le président
turc. Après quatre heures
de discussions...
Une percée inattendue.
Les négociateurs ukrainiens ont
proposé que leur pays devienne
neutre, sans présence militaire
étrangère sur son territoire.
Les négociateurs ukrainiens ont
proposé que leur pays devienne
neutre, sans préseire
étrangère sur son territoire.
En échange : un accord
international ferait en sorte
que des pays comme
les États-Unis, la France,
Israël, la Turquie ou même
le Canada, seraient garants
de la sécurité de l'Ukraine.
Une entente inspirée de l'OTAN
avec une clause de protection
. L'Ukraine réclame
aussi la paix sur l'ensemble
de son territoire, et que
la proposition soit soumise
à un référendum.
Kiev suggère aussi une période
de consultation de 15 ans sur
le statut de la Crimée, annexée
illégalement par la Russie
Le négociateur russe évoque
des pourparlers constructifs.
La proposition sera soumise
à Vladimir Poutine.
Et pour favoriser le dialogue,
la Russie propose un apaisement.
De réduire radicalement
les activités militaires de
la Russie dans les régions Kiev
et Tchernihiv.
Le chef de la diplomatie turque
parle des progrès les plus
importants depuis le début
des pourparlers.
Mais sur le terrain, les
obstacles demeurent nombreux.
La France n'a pas réussi à
convaincre Vladimir Poutine
d'accepter une opération
d'évacuation dans la ville
de Marioupol, où sont coincés
160 000 civils. La ville est
pilonnée sans cesse depuis
la fin février.
"Ce que les troupes russes font
à Marioupol est un crime contre
l'humanité", a déclaré
le président ukrainien, deva
des parlementaires danois.
Washington et Londres restent
prudents face aux promesses
d'accalmie de la Russie.
Au-delà des paroles,
les Occidentaux attendent
de voir quelles seront
les actions des militaires
russes sur le terrain.
Cette avancée diplomatique est
un point de départ, mais
les tractations pourraient
durer des années.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Par